Enough of this!
You never stood a chance.
A Bronze Knight like you
was never going to overcome
a Gold Knight like me.
[groaning]
They were afraid
I would betray Sanctuary, too,
but I won't, ever!
Lightning Bolt!
[gasps]
No. It can't be.
Impossible!
Why would the Sagittarius Armor
protect you?
The Armor has a mind of its own.
[growls]
Brother, why?
You're about to find out
just how powerful I am!
[yells]
[sighs]
You took my sister,
just to kill her?
This isn't about your sister.
No one gives a damn about her.
This is about
the very survival of humanity!
[chuckles]
[grunts]
If mankind is to survive,
then Sienna must die!
Using the Gold Armor
to protect her is madness!
[gasps]
You're not serious, are you?
Huh?
You're a piece of garbage
if you believe in the prophecy
more than your brother!
What do you know
about my brother?
His failure has been a burden
that I've had to carry.
You're wrong!
Your brother
gave humanity one last chance.
Athena will fight for mankind,
no matter what,
and we support her to the death.
If you lose
your faith in Athena,
then what's the point
of being a Knight?
Silence!
It's our job to stop
the prophecy from happening,
to keep the peace,
to save humanity!
Enough!
Pegasus Ryu-Sei-Ken!
Lightning Bolt!
[yells]
You may wear
the Armor of a Gold Knight,
but we both know
you're unworthy.
You're the unworthy one.
You killed my sister.
Now you want to murder Athena.
I have to! It's the only way
to save mankind.
I'll protect Sienna.
I may not be as smart as you
or know exactly everything
that's happening around us...
but I know she's a human being,
and I'm going to protect her.
For a moment,
you sounded like my brother,